my god simon just got me the
coolest gift ever it is
kimopoli what do you get the girl who
has
literally everything her very own custom
monopoly
duh like how did this become a thing
that's right
kim kardashian turns 40 years old on
wednesday and on monday
she hit up her insta story to share the
over-the-top b-day gift from her
long-time pal
simon huck every last thing
that's my first apartment that i ever
had
that is my our first house that we
filmed keeping up with the kardashians
in
momagertax my first house that i bought
my dad's house my best friend allison's
house
the hospital that i was born in skim's
hq my dad's business
the street i lived on you guys literally
simon i'm done
so all of kim's other friends just pack
it up and call it a day
because simon just won the prize for
best gift of all time
that's my car my old rolls my white
rolls
all of these are like memories look at
that
go to jail that's my high school
glam tax seriously i'm dying look at
these little
um things literally every last thing
mean something a weight a tv a camera
a hashtag literally this is the cutest
thing
ever with my nude colors it's honestly
perfect
simon i love you and we're gonna be
playing monopoly
very soon how much do you want to bet
kimopoli hits shelves in 2021
just saying i mean simon really thought
of it all
he even had chance cards this one says
pay north security detail 15
this one says jeff latham's floral bills
how funny let's go to ocean drive
take a trip to marymount high school
that's my high school guys look at all
of these
this is so funny
these cards what does this one say your
law firm kkw partners
wins a huge case how cute is this
and community chest cards dr orion
injection
fees private jets skim
stock surges oh my god you land a quick
trim endorsement
oh my god kim's a princess tax refund
easy stock this is so
met gala night collect fifty dollars
from every player
oh my gosh is this not so cute it's so
crazy
here's a fun little game drink every
time kim says kimopoli
is cute this is the cutest thing ever
how cute is this oh my gosh is this not
so cute here to confirm kim it
is the cutest thing ever and the card it
read quote
celebrating 40 years of you in game form
happy birthday to the most loyal ride or
die love you
and that's how it's done folks oh thank
you to honor the birthday girl's
milestone b
day e will be playing a marathon of
keeping up with the kardashians
featuring the kkw beauty founder's most
iconic episodes
and moments like the first time we saw
kim's ugly cry face
oh funny get out if you're gonna
continue to laugh and make fun of me
you're tired of it
i start laughing at kim when she's
crying because i just can't help it
she has this ugly crying face that she
makes
that time she wouldn't stop taking
selfies in the car as khloe kardashian
was reporting to jail
and would you stop taking pictures of
yourself your sister's going to jail
and the one time kim lost her earring in
the ocean
[Music]
oh yeah and the purse moment don't be
rude
and the whole day will come to a head
with kim's 40th birthday special
where the kardashian jenners will take a
look back at their favorite memories
with kim
it's always so much fun
you